meanwhile the big squeeze over the 95
515 getting a little shifty just maybe
when you were starting to get used to
those two lanes only in both directions
of the freeway between the spaghetti
ball and eastern and dot decides to keep
you on your toes first on the northbound
side you were supposed to be down to
just one lane from eastern las vegas
boulevard this morning supposedly
wrapped up at six i don't know if they
did that bottom line tonight into
tomorrow
they're going to have you down to one
lane for that short but sometimes very
crowded stretch from the boulevard into
the spaghetti bowl so heads up then
tomorrow night into wednesday they're
switching over to the southbound side
with only one length from the spaghetti
bowl to las vegas boulevard then
wednesday night and thursday they're
taking away a couple of on-ramps to the
northbound 95 from eastern and from las
vegas boulevard more goes on later in
the week too we want you to check that
out along with the link to ndot's
website that covers the whole project
i515project.com but we have that link on
as well as all of our driving you crazy
stories on our website eightnewsnow.com
you click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone and if there's something
driving you crazy you can email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com